à l'aide d'une carte et d'une boussole
les orienteurs doivent relier le départ
à l'arrivée le plus vite possible en
choisissant le meilleur itinéraire
suivre les chemins les ruisseaux coupés
à travers bois et pendant ce temps le
chronomètre tourne sur la deuxième étape
du Trophée de 50 ans en Yvelines 5
circuits sont au programme allant de 2 à
7,5 km et dans le peloton quelques
orienteurs un peu particuliers sont
prêts à avaler le tracé chaque mercredi
on est sur un une forêt différente
aujourd'hui ça se particulier parce que
c'est mille villes biforet donc c'est
pas très fréquent et haut ce genre de
d'alternative et de circuit donc voilà
c'est perturbant la ville parce que on
change complètement de
l'environnement c'est plus la forêt
c'est la ville donc avec des gingembre
particulières et c'est tout aussi
intéressant
le piège avec l'étape du encourtoise et
justement la partie ville il ne faut pas
se tromper de trottoir ou de coin de rue
dans le quartier des garennes ou des
saules et avec en point d'orgue un petit
labyrinthe à l'entrée du parc de la
Bièvre
et quand on voit les concurrents courir
dans tous les sens on se demande parfois
qui est sur le bon chemin au milieu des
collines il faut s'arrêter quelques
secondes pour se situer sur la carte et
trouver le prochain point de contrôle
sur le circuit de 6 km le jeune
Guyancourtois Nicolas Bayle a été le
plus rapide et s'est imposé en un peu
plus de 44 minutes les 290 participants
se donnent déjà rendez-vous à Chevreuse
ce mercredi pour la troisième course